hey 42 here according to YouTube's
analytics roughly 80% of people watching
this video are under 35 years old
marketers have invented a name for this
demographic of impressionable young
people they're called Millennials others
have labeled them
Generation Y a millennial is anyone born
after 1980 that includes myself and most
of my viewers in fact Millennials now
outnumber every other generation but
according to multiple studies we are the
most depressed generation ever
Psychology Today reports that the
suicide rate amongst young adults has
tripled since the 1950s and terrifyingly
suicide is now the second most common
cause of death amongst college students
between 2005 and 2014 the number of
clinically depressed teenagers increased
by more than half a million
three-quarters of whom were women every
year more and more Millennials are
taking time off work and seeking help
for mental health issues an even greater
number report extremely low job
satisfaction and say that they
experience difficulty maintaining
relationships young people get a lot of
stick the older generation have always
experienced Juvenal a fear or hostility
directed at the younger generation this
is nothing new baby boomers born just
after the war had a strong work ethic
and believed that the amount of hours
worked should be directly relational to
their income baby boomers heavily
begrudged as the generation that came
after them
Generation X they were more independent
they changed their careers more often
and believed in a fair work/life balance
and now it has come full circle once
again baby boomers and Generation Xers
alike are resenting Generation Y the
Millennials you have brand new values
such as collaboration worked up actually
meaningful and impactful
having fun in the workplace and of
course free food do previous generations
look down on us just because we're
different or is it more than that even
Time magazine has posted the Millennial
beast calling goes lazy entitled
narcissists who still live of their
parents out what unfortunately they
could have a point
unlike the generational divides of last
century there is a lot of research on
statistics that suggest everybody label
Millennials have been tarred with maybe
well deserved even if it isn't strictly
through our own fault the cold hard
facts don't lie the volume of incidents
of narcissistic personality disorder is
three times higher for people currently
in their twenties than the average are
we really all in love with ourselves
because we receive 50 likes on our
latest selfie experts believe there are
very real observable causes of this
heightened narcissism Millennials are
the first generation that were brought
up on reality television and every year
more and more superficial Pro reality
programming is shoved down our throats
such programs are the thais narcissism
above all else portraying looks and
popularity as the source of fame and
happiness in such shows real human
relationships are often shown as being
cheap and disposable and then of course
there's a social media swamp that drowns
us all in a sea of like shares pins and
follows countless studies have shown
that dopamine the pleasure chemical is
released in the brain when we receive
likes on our photos and videos this
system breeds narcissism as its very
core it appears that the more
narcissistic we are and the more selfies
we upload the more likes we will
inevitably receive and sadly this
actually makes us happier experts also
accusers and being entitled a recent
study revealed that 40% of Millennials
believe they should be promoted every
two years even if they haven't earned it
research shows up its entitlement to be
given handouts regardless of one's
performance stems from an unusual place
remember school sports day even if you
came in last place you still got a
trophy just for participating but even
if you didn't as chosen we were always
rewarded for taking part somehow if
they're taking part that counts remember
countless studies have proven that this
attitude creates a disingenuous and
diluted sense of achievements and can be
deeply damaging to our future
expectations of what it really takes to
achieve something this philosophy is
unique to our generation Generation Xers
baby boomers and all those before them
were all brought up in a deeply
competitive environment it was instilled
within them from a very young age that
rewards have to be earned through hard
work and graft they were not told that
they were entitled to anything the
so-called Silent Generation that lived
through both world wars certainly didn't
feel entitled they lived through the
hardest period of modern history and
everything they had earned they had to
cling onto with their lives
quite literally this meant that when
they brought up their children the baby
boomers they instilled within them a
strict mentality of saving every penny
and an extremely hard work ethic they
were told that nothing in life was for
free or even expected it was all up to
them the baby boomers grew up and had
children of their own Generation X and
thus they passed on the same hard work
ethic but then a huge shift happened in
the global economy that changed
everything
Generation X Allah through a time of
great prosperity industry was on the
rise and the world was finally dragging
itself out of the pit static dug for
itself during the war this gave Gen Xers
a can-do attitude and so they taught
their children also millenials that if
you put your mind to it you can do
anything become anyone and let
very successful happy life you are
special this has created a generation of
people who all believe that they are
special I mean why wouldn't they
their parents have always drilled into
their heads that they are special and
unique Millennials are also completely
Fame obsessed four times as many
teenagers would choose to be the
assistant of a famous person rather than
the CEO of a major corporation in a
recent poll when asked what they would
like to do for a career 54% of 16 year
olds answered become a celebrity the far
gone are the days when becoming a
celebrity was just a side effect of
demonstrating unique talents to the
masses Millennials are also lazier we
have grown up with technology that can
think for us and therein lies the
biggest problem that's ruining the lives
of young people
today mobile phones I know you've heard
it a hundred times mobile phones are bad
for you
but do you really know why and just how
damaging they are for our mental health
because the research is terrifying so
just imagine you're out enjoying a meal
at a restaurant with family or friends
how many times do you check your phone
over the course of that meal the average
millennial checks their phone over 100
times per day and they took tap or swipe
on their phone over 3,000 times per day
why because we're all addicts I
mentioned earlier that receiving likes
releases do for me well so does hundreds
of other things that we do with our
phones taking a picture of your food
taking a selfie I think a status update
that you just cook the most amazing
omelet of your life all of these acts
release dopamine even before we upload
them to the Internet the dopamine is
released in advance because our brains
anticipate the multitude of likes and
shares it should hopefully receive
within seconds we start to receive
feedback this is instant gratification
instant approval from our peers and it
goes on and on round
clock we receive instant gratification
when we wake up peer approval before we
go to bed and throughout the middle of
the night the dopamine swirls and swirls
in our brain in an everlasting continuum
of self-fulfillment and reward this only
serves to perpetuate our narcissism
until it stops when we upload a photo of
our chia seed and avocado toast and it
doesn't receive as much attention as we
hoped in our minds our peers have
rejected us we are now lost without
purpose we are now depressed does all
this sound familiar
this cycle of massive releases of
dopamine followed by periods of intense
sadness sounds very much like an alcohol
or gambling addiction doesn't it whether
we like it or not we have become a
generation of addicts we check our
phones at dinner because we're addicted
it's the reason we put it on the table
next to our food putting the people we
should be spending quality face-to-face
time with in second priority to a little
dopamine device it's the reason we don't
talk to people on the boss on the train
at school or at work we instead indulge
wholly in our addiction because we are
truly addicted and most of us don't even
realize a survey of more than 2,000
Millennials found that 93% use their
phones in bed and 80% use their phones
on the toilet but it isn't your fault
Millennials are simply a product of the
environment this is the hand we were
dealt we grew up in a time of rapid
technological advancement and as long as
mobile devices continue to generate
enormous profits then companies will
continue to develop new digital
mechanisms and social networks that
provide us with instant gratification
and it keeps coming quicker and quicker
we no longer have to wait for our next
fix it's instantaneous
we have Snatcher Facebook Instagram
Twitter Pinterest what's up
any of which can provide our next fix
whenever we desire it and if not we can
simply connect some digital candy
to make us feel better our parents
didn't have these distractions they had
to put time and effort into receiving
the approval of that peers they had to
have meaningful conversations and formed
strong deep and long-lasting
relationships with both their friends
and partners to get their dopamine fix
at work they had to grab day after day
and when that promotion came along my
god did they deserve it
in contrast Millennials have become
immensely impatient we are so used to
instant gratification that if we don't
get a promotion 10 minutes after we
start a new job we get bored of it
because it isn't a sort of timeline that
we're used to we say we want to make an
impact yet we expect to do so within our
first six months as a new job and when
six months or a year has gone by and
we're still a tea and coffee guy for the
office it makes us feel disenfranchised
worthless and depressed but it's not
your fault you have grown up in a
maelstrom of dopamine on tap whenever
you desire it so naturally you expect
the same instant fulfillment from your
career and relationships but we can't
tap a button to help us achieve that
there is no virtual replacement for hard
work and genuine conversations we can't
swipe right to get promoted and I'm
sorry folks but it's going to take more
than commenting on your partner's later
selfie to make them feel genuinely
valued and lost take them on a date for
goodness sake and don't look at your
phone for the entire time because the
moment you do they are now second
priority so should we be worried about
the future of a world run bodies oh so
terrible Millennials are Millennials
really so ill-prepared to fill the boots
of the previous generation in ten to
twenty years time these narcissistic
self-obsessed lazy entitled young adults
you want success handed to them on a
plate you can't tie down a relationship
or achieve satisfaction in the workplace
because they're too addicted to social
media well I wouldn't be so worried yes
we young people have our issues but
we're at
no difference to the last generation
Generation X were also labeled as
entitled and lazy when they were young
as a society we need to recognize that
the world has completely changed both
technologically and culturally over the
past 20 years and Millennials are the
first adopters of this strange new
lifestyle where you can build a
billion-dollar business from your
bedroom if you put your mind to it
all our apparent faults are merely
symptoms of trying to adapt to a
completely strange new way of life that
our parents didn't have to deal with we
face new and unique pressures stresses
and challenges and we need to find
better ways to cope with them rather
than indulging in social media and for
all our faults there are actually a lot
of good things to say about Millennials
but I rarely brought up Millennials are
the most vulnerable generation ever
research shows that prejudice has fallen
with each new generation and Millennials
are far less racist homophobic and
sexist than their parents the Pew
Research asked adults aged between 18 to
29 what their most important priority
was during their lifetime 52 percent
answered being a good parent 30 percent
said have a successful marriage
twenty-one percent replied helping
others in need now that doesn't sound
like a generation as it completely
self-absorbed now does it and our
inability to settle into a normal 9 to 5
job may not be entirely due to our
reliance on social media maybe it's
because we all want more than their
monotonous normality of working for some
heartless corporate giants research
showed that Millennials are the most
entrepreneurial generation ever spurred
on by young giving yourself success
stories like Elon Musk and Mark
Zuckerberg as a generation we have an
unstoppable appetite to achieve
something big and make an impact right
after we finish sending is hilarious
nurture this mentality might be proving
difficult the large corporation
who need to employ cheap young labor
that can sit in an office and cause
button for eight hours a day but it
certainly is changing the world in ways
our parents could have never imagined
there's no doubt we need to spend more
time interacting with one another and
less time on social media all the
research has shown that it does bad
things for our mental health but we also
need to accept that the world is rapidly
changing Millennials have their faults
sure but they are also contributing to
the world in so many incredible ways
just like the generation before us and
the generation before them change has
always come and always will it is
inevitable so we need to find a way to
work with it for the better instead of
spending our time pointing out the
faults in others thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video then please
click here to support me on patreon
which helps me to make better videos and
you can get some pretty cool rewards it
click here to watch another video and if
you haven't already don't forget to
subscribe